what's going on guys this is rob and
after watching the doctor strange 2 fate
trailer and just existing on social
media the number one question people
have been asking is what are the new
monsters everybody wants to know and a
lot of people were speculating that it
was
and it kind of makes sense the biggest
problem with that is that as the trailer
goes on there is actually a point where
when the scarlet witch lands there's a
second one behind her not only that
scarlet witch and wong are both looking
past the camera and wong is brandishing
his weapons his magical shield and
whatnot which indicate that like they're
looking at enemies that way now the fact
that these two monsters are looking at
them and they're looking the other way
indicates there's more monsters in the
space so in effect i would surmise
they're probably surrounded so the
question is what are these things now
you guys aren't far off if they're if
they're what i think they are now keep
in mind marvel cinematic universe
changes stuff all the time but if
they're what i think they are the idea
of catholine is actually incredibly
accurate so here's what we're gonna do
gather round children gather around papa
rob is gonna tell you a story
[Laughter]
so in the video that we did about khan
shu we're about moon night where we
talked about khanshu basically being the
brother of the panther god bast and that
this is a way that the marvel cinematic
universe can actually link the moon
knight mythos directly to the black
panther mythos and basically say their
relatives in terms of how in terms of
their form and function we talked about
the whole idea of the war between the
elder gods right that at the beginning
of all things on earth there were the
elder gods you had geothon and a whole
bunch of other people they ended up
descending into absolute madness they
went to war with each other and then the
sentience of mother earth basically got
knocked up by a being called a tomb
which destroyed all the elder gods but
people like catholic managed to find a
way out the way this worked and it's
really really really cool it's a
combination of things we actually get
this from uh some of it is from old
school stories like marvel preview
number seven and then some of it comes
from like relatively newer things like
uh dark hold pages from the book of sin
number
three or number seven or something like
that in 1993 right so you kind of get it
from different sources but the overall
gist here is that following the
destruction of the elder gods at the
hands of a tomb who went into the sun
and became almond rock that cathode had
taken off to his own dimension that was
called the flickering realms now the
reason why they call the flickering
realms is because it quite literally
changes consistently it can be any like
virtually anything right so one moment
it can be like an entire realm made of
ice the next moment it can be
essentially hell as far as you're
concerned like fire brimstone eternal
damnation that kind of a thing right so
it just flickers and changes all the
time now when catholic created that
realm he created it as what was called
an inner plane and the reason why is
because if you think about dimensions in
marvel comics as something akin to the
rings of saturn right earth itself being
the main planet and then the planes of
existence being the rings of saturn the
further out you go the more you get into
like the outer planes so this this whole
realm of the flickering realms was
called the inner planes because what it
did is it allowed cathode to maintain
proximity to earth so that he could
actually influence what was going on in
earth hence the reason why he created
the dark hold and then it was on earth
for people to access and then use and
basically he would grant them a portion
of his power but he would in turn take
their soul so very similar to like
mephisto albeit without the trickery but
the thing about this is that uh inside
of his own realm before he essentially
went and started sleeping right because
he literally just kind of went into a
slumber is how marvel explains it what
he did is he created a race now this is
where things get a little murky here he
created a group that was called the
angari i think is how you pronounce it
technically it's spelled in apostrophe
g-a-r-a-i so i don't know exactly how
you pronounce that uh but basically this
was a race that had actually occupied
earth for a period of time this kind of
interdimensional period or i guess uh
inter period between the destruction of
the elder gods and then when humanity
started taking its rightful place but
before the celestial showed up to
basically mess with humanity and modify
their genes and so the angari ruled
earth for like a few million years and
then ultimately the angari were defeated
now in marvel preview number seven we're
never really given an answer as to why
right it's literally a story that
focuses on some girl named setano who's
not important at all but the thing about
it is just like some force defeated them
and that's all we really get but the
thing about this is that the angari were
basically created by cathone for the
purpose of carrying out his schemes and
his mechanisms now let's look at the
marvel cinematic universe there's a few
things to notice here looking at this
trailer one they're all red now the
whole idea behind this is you could say
well maybe it's just the environment
that they're in to a degree maybe but
wong does not have a red tinge about him
he doesn't look red right i mean he's
just a guy he looks like his normal self
right he's wong you know so because of
that like they basically match the
scarlet witch in appearance now as we
know the scarlet witch manipulates chaos
magic and chaos magic is literally the
source of power from catholic is one of
the only i think he and the scarlet
witch are the only ones who can actually
use chaos magic technically doctor
strange could invoke it if he tried but
he doesn't mess with that kind of magic
and so at the end of the day like
catholic being the really the source of
chaos magic makes him absurdly powerful
i would go as far as to argue catholic
is probably the second most powerful
magic wielder in the entirety of of
existence in marvel comics the only
exception being zomb and zom was so
powerful it took the living tribunal to
defeat him right and then lock him away
in some dimension somewhere and so where
doctor strange can invoke the power of
zom he rarely ever does it and when he
does it's just a tiny little bit of it
otherwise he risks being completely
possessed by zom and then basically
being a vector for zom to show back up
in the main marvel universe in which
case everybody would be screwed like no
one would be able to overpower zom
infinity gauntlet or not no one would be
able to overpower that guy it's just
he's it's just a whole different level
of power it's absolutely ridiculous but
the thing about this is that looking at
cathone right cathone while he's not
necessarily a crimson character right
that's more sidorak who is basically
imbued by the color red historically
speaking in terms of how cathode's been
depicted in relation to the scarlet
witch red has basically been the primary
color and that seems to be the theme in
the marvel cinematic universe with this
right the the whole idea of the
multiverse of madness that america
chavez is actually the one teaching
doctor strange about the multiverse
instead of the other way around so on
and so forth and so it's one of those
things where it really really does look
like it's the angari race now what does
this mean if it is the reality here is
that while the angari were very very
powerful in marvel comics in truth i
would say they're probably just going to
be regular run-of-the-mill henchmen
around here albeit on a magical and far
more powerful level than we're
traditionally used to seeing now do i
think that means that we're going to see
cathone in this movie i would say
probably not um i don't think we really
seek a throne here and here's the reason
why catholic's a big bad right this
guy's a big deal i mean it's huge like
you think thanos with the infinity
gauntlet was a problem no that guy's
nothing compared to the power of
catholic he's on a wholly different
level and so i have a hard time
believing because from what we've seen
in the various rumors that are coming
out here and really even marvel seems to
have confirmed it that the evil doctor
strange which largely seems to be the
what-if version of doctor strange is the
main villain of this film that's kind of
what's you know the the discussion
that's happening as far as the
scuttlebutt so not 100 sure we don't
really know until the movie definitively
comes out uh but if that's the case
cathode is not going to be an
afterthought villain but he's not going
to be a guy where it's just like well
you know evil doctor strange what's the
prelude and now cathode is the main bad
guy if anything i would say this would
serve as a vector if we were going to
see some kind of enemy like some kind of
main bad guy within the realm of the
dimension of the of the angari it would
probably be kirak the damn he was the
leader of the ingary group by the ingary
race like he was like smarter than all
of them he was like their chieftain
ridiculously powerful more than enough
for doctor strange and i wouldn't be
surprised if it would require the
efforts of doctor strange and wanda and
wong in order to overpower that guy
right i mean he's it's crazy how
powerful he is when he first showed up
it was actually because cyclops was
losing his mind and basically ended up
hitting an obelisk which accidentally
freed kiroka damned literally his
arrival just overwhelmed professor
xavier because of how evil he was xavier
just like his mind just couldn't handle
it and you're talking about the most
powerful telepath in the universe so
it's kind of crazy when you when you get
to that level of just pure evilness let
alone the power that goes with it but
what i will say and what i wouldn't be
surprised about when it comes to this is
that this would be a vector and lead
into the the whole thing with cathode at
some future point in time and the reason
why is because as you guys know when it
comes to the marvel cinematic universe
they are in a lot of ways about the slow
build right i mean they it literally
took him 10 years to get to the infinity
saga and while feiny and them have come
out and said they don't really intend to
do any more 10-year arcs it would make
sense that if they were going to bring
cathone in as a major player as a major
villain for wanda or doctor strange or
whoever to face off against because it
looks like they're largely building up
the magical side it's kind of its own
thing right and and that goes wherever
it ends up going it would make sense
that they wouldn't necessarily introduce
him here instead what they would do is
they would say okay so cathone became
aware of wanda when she started messing
with the dark hole and it's just kind of
like damn like i wonder how powerful
this girl is so i wouldn't be surprised
with everything that's going on cathode
is watching and cathode is just kind of
waiting for his perfect time to be able
to intervene and to act i wouldn't
necessarily say he lured wanda there to
the dimension of the angari in order to
see her face off against them and get an
idea of how powerful she is i would say
if anything he's just kind of waiting
and watching as far as why it is that
they're there i wouldn't be surprised if
the movie has some sort of element where
like they have to go gather individual
things or they're trying to understand
what's going on with the multiverse
what's leading to these chaotic events
right that whole scene that whole
situation may be fairly early on right
and like the catalyst behind it is
basically schumaguera showing up on
earth and doctor strange is being like
okay something's off this guy shouldn't
be here how did this guy get here and
then as he goes and investigates he
comes across america chavez or whatever
it is you know while well you know he's
fighting against uh against schumer
gorath because she's in that scene and
then in turn the two of them end up
going on quote-unquote and adventure
across the multiverse you know or
however that whole plot unfolds but
they're basically there because they
need to be right because you know some
kind of artifact or something has to be
gathered but that area requires their
attention and while they're there
suddenly they come across the ingary but
again i'm not swearing by any of this
right i'm not telling you guys this is
an absolute definitively that's what's
going on but if you're asking for my
best guess on what i think those
monsters are my best guess is that
they're the angari they were a race
created by catholic for the purpose of
conquering and subjugating basically
beings on earth and we're ultimately
defeated somewhere along the line and
we're just sent back to their dimension
which exists inside the dimension of uh
of of catholic right so basically like a
closet and a house it's kind of how
their how their realms work together so
with that being said guys i'm really
curious to see how this plays out i mean
the movie just these trailers just get
me more and more excited these little tv
spots and whatnot get me more and more
excited tickets go on sale this week i'm
getting mine as soon as they're as soon
as they're available but uh yeah thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace